on the plus side it's been the longest
birthday I've ever had on the minus side
everybody's under an evil spell Real
Talk Jane do you have any idea how
awesome you are
Minnie fancy you as the unsung hero of
descendants three Carlos was lucky to be
with a smart go-getter like you if only
you could see what the rest of the world
sees you are obsessed with magic but the
truth is you are magic and we love to
watch you shine so own it girl there's
one descendant who is more than she
appears to be and one villain kid saw
that before everyone else that's why he
fell hopelessly in love with her there
are so many things about Jane that
nobody realizes watch until the end to
find out what secret magical powers Jane
possesses do you guys remember when Jane
stepped into her power in descendants
two she was a boss in charge of the
entire cotillion and it was epic she
definitely came a long way since her
days of following Audrey around in the
first Descendants movie but Jane's
journey reveals something you may have
missed about the fairy godmothers
daughter let's start at the beginning
Jane started out as a shy sweet little
auradon gal who was afraid of the
villain kids from the Isle that's okay
don't mind me as you were
Jane was fascinated with magic even
though her mother wouldn't let her
anywhere near it Jane had trouble
figuring out who she truly was in the
first movie that's why she helped Audrey
bully now she had no self-confidence
this lack of self-esteem cost her to
only see her value in her appearance but
we all know now that there is so much
more to her than that once Jane slowly
started to accept the DK she started to
accept herself as well
becoming friends with Mallon or crew
helped Jane to see that it's not just
about your outside appearance it's
what's inside your heart that counts
that's when she really takes the lead in
descendants
- Jane steps into the leadership role
indeed to with the planning of the
cotillion she is much more outgoing and
happy this makes her ear resist
to build a Carlos but along with the
newfound confidence comes a bit of
cluelessness she gets frazzled easily
during the planning of the big
celebration and she's totally oblivious
to Carlos having a crush on her when he
tries to ask her out he has to explain
over and over again what he means would
you be my date for cotillion Carlos is
so happy when she finally says yes and
let's not forget jean is the one who
tried to stop Ana Numa from getting
together by unveiling Ben's gift from
Ella at the cotillion by accepting the
villain kid she started accepting
herself as well but Jane's
transformation in d3 was the most
surprising one of all keep watching to
find out more about her secret powers in
d3 Jane doesn't know why Carlos misses
her birthday celebration but even then
she still believes in Carlos and sure
Jane can be a bit naive sometimes but
she's still outsmarts Audrey she jumps
into the enchanted lake to avoid
succumbing to Audrey's sleep spell Jane
calls to warn Ben and also tries to call
her mom so she could get her wand and
put a stop to the madness
she takes action rather than staying on
the sidelines and she saves the day
again when she sprays Ben with water
from the enchanted lake to turn him back
from the Beast to man where did this
Jane come from she just did what needed
to be done she didn't ask for permission
from anyone
Jane has come a long way since the first
descendants movie and can we talk about
what a cute couple Jane and Carlos are
even when she thought Carlos forgot her
birthday all she cared about was if he
was alright and he was so happy to see
her that birthday gift Carlos got for
Jane was perfect
jar lows forever it broke our hearts
when Jane saw that her mom was turned to
stone but this is the biggest moment
when we see Jane's true self shine she
is now the one reassuring and rescuing
her mother she has to rely on the very
magic that her mother forbade her to use
not that long ago
Jane represents the heart of the movie
she is kind brave and in charge
the
ol Jane would have crumbled under this
kind of pressure but this new and
improved Jane finally understands the
impact she can have on auradon here's
the truth about Jane that nobody
realizes Jane knows just how strong and
mighty the power of love can be she
knows that you can change an entire
kingdom by connecting with the person
right in front of you Jane took the time
and effort to encourage every person she
met and when her mom was turned back
into her human self Jane was there to
comfort her she told her mom that it's
okay this heart-to-heart connection that
Jane fosters between herself and others
makes her the unsung hero of The
Descendants movies mal and Audrey went
through some major transformations
throughout the descendants movies but
Jane also grew and changed significantly
she didn't understand that she had power
without magic all along but by the end
of d3 she notes that her magical powers
are leadership and compassion in the
future we can see our becoming a great
ambassador for auradon sitting right
next to mal and then on the throne all
leaders must have courage and compassion
and that is why Jane is the queen of
compassion do you think Jane is the
unsung hero of descendant 3 if so leave
a star emoji down below if you disagree
tell us who you think the real hero of
descendants 3 is in the comments thank
you for watching hit that subscribe
button and notification Bell to be the
first to know when we post a new video
and don't forget to give us a big thumbs
up we'll see you later
[Music]